[Music]
I'm Keith Olbermann and this is the
resistance what Trump's new best friend
Vladimir Putin did to this country by
computer what Putin intends to do again
with or without Trump's help what that
Kremlin connected lawyer reportedly had
in mind on June 9th 2016 the Trump jr.
and Kushner and mana fort were
apparently all too happy to hear about
this whole cyber nightmare has now been
compared publicly to a terrorist attack
by Isis and amazingly that is altogether
correct and appropriate yet it may still
be insufficient 50 years ago this month
I saw a work of fiction in which war had
become so sophisticated that it could be
entirely simulated by computer no bombs
no destruction no huge budgets a
supercomputer would simply calculate how
many on each side would die in a given
nuclear attack and that number of
citizens on each side would
matter-of-factly report to their own
government to be killed this was 1967
and I was eight years old and real
nuclear war was a constant daily
inescapable threat in American life yet
this work of fiction somehow terrified
me even more than that reality did it
was something beyond evil yet utterly
plausible about the detachment the mass
murder by proxy the ability for one
civilization to destroy another by
computer the work of fiction was called
a taste of Armageddon and it was a
Robert Hamner short story transformed
into of all things the 23rd episode of
the original series Star Trek it has
stayed with me for half a century and
nothing I have experienced since had
quite captured that same mixture of
terror and detachment and then I read an
op-ed piece in The Washington Post and
the true evil of the Russian cyber war
against our electoral process last year
and the potential cyber war for next
year and Donald Trump's criminal
indifference to both came into full
perspective for me we are not yet
reporting to the disintegration booths
of a taste of Armageddon because
the Kremlin's cyberwarfare desk has told
us to but we are sending our freedoms in
to be destroyed the piece was written by
an associate dean at the yale law school
named asha ram kapoor who teaches
courses in national security law at yale
and other institutions and who from 2002
to 2005 as the washington post article
notes was a FBI special agent
specializing in counterintelligence I
was an FBI agent Trump's lack of concern
about Russian hacking shocks me I'd like
to do something I don't usually do here
I'd like to read much of MS Ranga paws
conclusion it is as terrifying and
already as seared into my memory as that
science fiction about bloodless
computerised war from fifty years ago
she writes the Russia case is different
because it's operation last year did not
simply try to use the American system as
a vehicle for Russia's benefit instead
Russia essentially attempted to break
the system itself by hacking political
parties computer and email systems
flooding the media with disinformation
and purposely sowing political chaos in
the voting process which is the bedrock
of our democracy although its activities
didn't involve bombs or dead bodies
Russia's efforts were no less dangerous
than a terrorist attack in fact the
insidiousness of Russia's interference
lies in its invisibility the American
public did not even know that their
freedom of choice was potentially being
manipulated and distorted for foreign
interests for any president to ignore
the situation is shocking my former
colleagues at the FBI who are working on
this case and have uncovered the full
scale of Russia's efforts must be
incredulous at trump's cavalier attitude
what miss ron Kapaa wrote next is both
clarifying and terrifying to understand
their perspective consider this
happening in the context we normally
think of as a national security threat
imagine that during the 2016
presidential election a candidate
publicly invited the Islamic state to
bomb the Democratic Party headquarters
and then imagine that such a bombing in
fact took place resulting in the worst
terror
attack in US history now further imagine
that the new president not only had no
interest in learning more about who
caused the attack or bringing them to
justice but in fact went out of his way
to make nice with the Islamic state and
offer them political and diplomatic
concessions finally imagine that there
may be evidence that members of the
president's campaign or other American
citizens were actively or passively
involved in facilitating such an attack
she concludes the fact pattern of the
Russian investigation so far is similar
and that's an investigation Comey says
Trump had no interest in following
closely regardless of which storyline
you believe about commis testimony it is
in the end a sideshow the real issue is
Russia's assault on our democracy and
how we respond to it if the president
intends to stay true to his oath both he
and all Americans regardless of
political affiliation will support the
FBI and getting to the bottom of the
Russian threat and making sure that it
never happens again
unquote Asha rang the pun writing in The
Washington Post more than one month ago
June 10th it escaped my attention for
nearly a month it should not escape
yours and it will stay with me just as
that television episode of computerized
bloodless war has stayed with me since
childhood it is what happened to our
country last year it explains what
happened to our country last year it
warns what will happen again to our
country next year and in 2020 and it
underscores that Donald Trump is doing
nothing to stop this and worse yet he is
enabling it floating and then backing
away from some joint form of cyber
security with the nation that everyone
but he and his apologists recognized
attacked us a taste of Armageddon
except we give one country control of
all the computers to survive as a nation
we must stop it and stop him resist
remove peace